oh my god eddie hearn
what a guy there's very few people no
i'm gonna change that
i've never met someone as
neurotically obsessed with success
and with winning and with accomplishing
things and with
living a life in constant forward motion
as my next guest
eddie hearn and it's remarkable because
when you unpack the reasons for that
obsession
and that dedication to being more and
achieving more
there's quite a fragile vulnerable
insecure
story that's something i've noticed with
a lot of my guests
and it often makes me think that the
most successful amongst us
aren't necessarily choosing to be
something's happened to them that's left
them with no choice
eddie han is one of the most notorious
sports promoters in the world he's
the king of boxing in this country he is
known for his no context and twitter
page which i'm sure a lot of you have
seen
but what i wanted to do when i sat down
with eddie herm was to get
underneath to get underneath the
external sort of braggadocious loud
promoter side of him
and to find out even in the case of
someone like eddie who is loud who is
successful who is ambitious who is a
promoter
are the same things true for him that
are true for you
the insecurities the vulnerabilities the
mental health issues
and how much does he really understand
himself my conversation with eddie was
incredibly enlightening but it also
wasn't that surprising
so without further ado i'm stephen
bartlett and this is the diary of a ceo
i hope nobody is listening but if you
are
then please keep this to yourself
you've done a ton of interviews
especially over the last couple of weeks
and there's this really consistent theme
that i felt in all of the interviews i
watched i watched you at cambridge
the high performance podcast loads of
them and um and then before we came
uh started filming today i had a chat
with frank
and he fully grasped on you know what he
said to me
which i which was also consistent with
these interviews is
that you are relentless and he was
telling me he's he's
had some um i probably shouldn't say
this but he was telling me he's i've
started having this uh is it
night owl or night night because eddie
will text me in the middle of the night
and he went i'll tell you one thing
about eddie
he is relentless you're what 40
41. 41 years old what's made you
that relentless at 41 years old to the
point where you're you're
uh pestering your colleagues at 3am in
the morning i don't know really
um i think when i when i did the book it
was like
it was quite a good um sort of
counseling session
with myself because i wasn't really
great at school i wasn't particularly a
hard worker
at school i loved the pound note always
and when i wrote the book it just i
started
writing about my childhood and
what it was like growing up and how i
was molded and
i think a lot of it comes down to the
fact that i love to win
and i'm a why did you love to win i
don't know because
with my dad that's what we did so
when we played cricket when we played
football when we played table tennis
when we sparred with each other
it was like for me growing up
you weren't you know i would come back
from a match say i played cricket and he
would go to me and actually my mum was
the same
and he would say to me how many runs you
get today son and i would say ah
four ah useless come on
next time knock in a fifty right it was
never
oh well well done son you know you took
part that's what
really matters that they taught me
taking part is completely and utterly
irrelevant
you win and ultimately sport is how i
was brought up i was brought up on the
foundations of sport
the lessons of sport the winning the
losing
you know the highs the lows but always
taught that winning was everything
so i i'm a failed athlete you know i
think any kid growing up would love to
be a sportsman now i played
qriket at a very good level but i was
never good enough for anything so
this is the next best thing but i think
if you're not trying to
win in life and win winning
it means something different to
everybody success means something
different to everybody
some people view success as being able
to get their pay packet on a weekend
you know be able to you know spend time
with her family
and have enough food on the you know
make enough money to have food on the
table and make sure everything's okay at
home and
and be happy you know and have a happy
life with no
no stress or no drama that's success to
a lot of people
but people's interpretation of success
is very different and
you know for me i i still don't know why
i i i do i know i know why i do this but
like you say i love it i guess that's
what it comes down to a passion for what
you do
and i don't know what the passion is is
it the passion that i love the sport of
boxing is it the passion that
i want to succeed against you know and
be bigger than my dad i think that's a
big part of it as well
or is it just that i love to win or is
it that i'm a bit sick in the head maybe
all of them
the sick and the head point i want to
play with that idea a little bit
um i write i i write in my book actually
we have the same publisher i wrote in my
book that the thing that invalidates you
when you're younger
becomes the thing you seek validation
from when you're older and what i meant
by that is like in my childhood
because we didn't have money um and i
was this black kid in a school of 1500
white kids
everything that we didn't have became
the things that i chased when i was
older or the thing that made me feel
somewhat invalid sometimes when i was a
kid
like you were saying about your dad
saying well you lost today became the
thing that i would seek validation from
as
as a as an adult and i wondered if that
resonated with you at all i mean like
well i had a different background i mean
my dad was poor
became rich and i was born so
i've said before it's not like when you
talk about generational wealth we didn't
have generational wealth
um i had a dad who was from dagenham
was from a council estate his dad was a
bus driver and then i grew up in this
sort of nouveau world where this bloke
had made his money and he was
you know i take the mickey out of him i
suppose he was a bit of a chav
you know he was like from dagnam and all
of a sudden he's got ferraris and big
cars and we used to have a white limo
and a black limo
that would drive like the snooker
players around and the fighters around
and i was horrible i was obnoxious
imagine like
a 14 15 year old kid hanging around with
eubank and naz and then you're in the
limo with your mates going up to london
or to romford for a night out i mean
i'll look back and just cringe
but mine was different you know and and
i guess
when it comes down to it and you know
again from the book and speaking and
speaking to people like frank lampard he
went to my school
um he was in the year above me at my
school i was
barry hern's son and frank lampard was
frank lampard's son
you know his dad played for west ham he
was and it's a different kind of drive
if you can make it flow in the right way
you know when you're talking about
sort of mindset and and and hustle
where all of a sudden i think so many
people with successful parents
end up just doing okay you know
but how do you go beyond that how do you
outperform
everything that he done and i will and i
feel like i've done that in many ways
but i will never be able to outperform
the fact that he came from
nothing my friends uh my friend is in a
very similar position you if i said my
friend's name you'd know the guy okay
his dad is a multi-billionaire
i know you know him because i've seen
you with him before actually in new york
but um his dad is a multi-billionaire
and he grew up with living in the shadow
and his dad was the same and i had a
conversation with him and he said
um it was all i was always trying to be
better than my dad he is now
a billionaire himself of his own doing
um
but it's just it's fascinating that and
he's that dad sounds very similar to
what your dad sounds where his dad was
tough on him
tough on him i think they're tough on
you because they don't want you to be
that spoiled kid i mean you always want
to
um spoil your kids you know you want to
give them the great even now you know
i've got two daughters
i love to spoil i work hard so i can
give them a great life
but i just want them to understand
manners
respect and discipline these are the
three most important things and he would
make sure
that i would understand that even by
having me working
you know giving me a clout every now and
again you know trying to keep because i
it must have been frustrating for him
because i was probably all the things
that he
resented when he was growing up and the
rich kid
oh with with parents who had got big
house and cars and
and i would have hated me at school you
know but he would have looked at me and
that's why he was so
disciplined with me and you know i was
in his slipstream growing up so i would
sit
you know we're here now that's that was
my house over there
so he would get home from work if he was
in the country
you know he would always go out and give
me a game of football cricket
and then he would go in the office all
night on the phone and i would have
dinner and i would just sit in the
office
you know i might have a ball just
throwing up in the air but i would some
subconsciously listen to the arguments
and
you know him losing his temper and and
just listen not because i wanted to
learn just because i was there
and you're talking there about the
sacrifice of
his success which is one of them as
you've highlighted is less time with
your family
you are relentless um everybody says
that
what is the the cost of being a
relentless person
you have to be incredibly selfish you
have to
you know for me family is the most
important thing but i have to be
brutally honest and say
i don't let even family get in the way
of things that i have to do
you know and that that can make you an
[ __ ] and it can make you sound
terrible but
i just don't know any way around it
there is no way you can be the perfect
husband
or the perfect father and run a
successful business
or you know be a you know
a relentless operator it's impossible
because i know because i try
to balance both but when you're flying
back from america
from a show and you land at seven
o'clock in the morning and then you go
to manchester for a press conference
and you come home and you just make it
to pick them up
from school and then you get back and
they say dad let's go over the park and
you're just
absolutely on empty and your phone's
going and you're trying to do another
deal and
you know you're pushing the swing and
you're going like this trying to send a
message at the same time
it's impossible you know listen i know
because sometimes
my eldest daughter is old enough to say
dad please get off the phone
and that's that kills me because that's
uh that's bad to hear you know i'm like
okay okay but then for 30 seconds later
i'm back just haven't looked down
because it's a lifestyle
you know and it's impossible to be great
at
anything without making sacrifices you
know it doesn't matter if you're a
fighter
if you're a sports when you speak to old
successful people
you can't be everything it's impossible
you know and and but what you don't want
to do is you don't want to disregard
your obligations your family obligations
because they are extremely important
but you also need a wife or a partner
who's understanding enough to say
this is what i know what he's like he
won't stop and that's why when frank
talks about the 3 a.m
4 a.m that's because a lot of the time
i'm sort of making up for the hour or
two
that i've lost out playing with the kids
so i'll put them to sleep they'll go to
sleep at nine
half nine you know chill out with a wife
for an hour she'll go to sleep and then
i'm up and now
with the growth in america it means that
at 4 p.m
5 p.m the west coast wakes up so i can't
go to bed
i can't disappear when it gets to 11
a.m or on the west coast or or midday on
the west coast because they want to
speak to me and we want to do business
i am much earlier in my career maybe 15
years earlier in my career
and um i've struggled with romantic love
for the very same reason that for the
last decade i've like slept in the
office
multiple weekends i've been obsessed um
i would
basically sacrifice everything and there
became this moment in my life where
i think it was maybe the day that
someone tried to buy the company
and i thought about what i'd spend it on
and i remember going home and i swear on
my mother's life i went on right move
and auto trader at the same i had two
tabs open
and i'm like the lamborghini tinder no
no no no
no that's that that always follows the
lamborghini so i was looking at this
lamborghini in this mansion the
countryside
and then i thought if i buy these things
i'm trading like this purpose i have
this job this you know
for for this lamborghini and this
mansion and it felt
really really empty and then i thought
that steve you know
when you were 18 and you were broke and
you had no money 18 year old steve said
wrote in your diary that's why it's
called the diversity that you wanted
the sports car the million before you
were 25. this was what we did it for
and then it threw my head into this like
confusion it's like if if it's not that
if that's gonna make me feel empty
they call it like um gold medal
depression where michael phelps won all
the medals and then got depressed
um then what's it all for and and then i
thought
and then also when does it all end like
when does it end
well it doesn't end because and actually
you you're always searching this is this
is a problem and something you have to
be careful of
because when you are trying to succeed
and when you're trying to become great
actually the great people
they never feel content with achievement
and i'm very much like that frank
lampard again going back to him
he said that when he won the champions
league she always dreamed to win in the
champions league and he stood there with
a trophy
and he felt nothing i mean he felt happy
but definitely not content definitely
not i've cracked it
that might go back to the sickness you
know that we talked about earlier and
when we talk about sickness i mean not
probably not medically sick but sick in
the head a little
bit to a point where i get it all the
time you know
we say that you know we wanted to do
you know when aj turned pro we wanted
him to be the world heavyweight champion
you know he won that great we was in the
ring after jumping up and down as soon
as we got out of the ring
the ma yeah and then it's like okay we
want to do something you know
we've got the klitschko fight okay you
go through it 90 000
at wembley you stand there everyone that
was at the event tells you it's a great
sporting occasion they've ever been to
how do you know uh at the time
amazing in the ring amazing you know and
then
not even the day after it's i i never i
never go out
really and i never drink really after a
show
because that's probably you know
depressed is the wrong word but you i go
back you know i finish the media
obligations
two three o'clock in the morning go back
to the hotel and that is when i'll sit
there
get into bed and then obviously you
can't sleep because the buzz and the
adrenaline
and that's when you just feel a little
bit low and empty is that okay
it's over same with what you talk about
with phelps it's the highs
versus the lows you can't just
experience the highs
and then be happy with the lows so you
want more and more
and more and more and i
i'm my i'm my own biggest critic and i'm
also very pessimistic
which is strange to a lot of people but
i kind of use it to play tricks on
myself to keep myself driven
so when i do something or when i plan
something i always say to myself
there's going to be problems i think
it's going to go wrong i doubt this will
happen
you know i don't know why i do it but it
just helps me to battle away to overcome
everything to get to the place
and then when i achieve something which
others might think is great
i say to myself that's nothing you've
got a long way to go because i'm scared
of sitting back
you know with the the cigar on the beach
again
i've cracked it you can't touch me you
know and we got to a position with uk
boxing where
you know we are virtually untouchable
but i just don't want to be that guy who
takes the foot off the gas i want to
bang every single nail in the coffin
you know and then move on to another
market and another market another market
but
you do get the worry with that mindset
is
you may look back when you're 80 or 90
and go
wow you know look at everything you've
done you never really enjoyed it did you
i mean i love what i do
but you probably should savor it a
little bit more than you do but again it
goes back to that mindset of being so
driven
you want the next drug success is a drug
but you've got to be careful that it
doesn't turn you into an [ __ ]
at the same time because how many
successful people do you know absolutely
horrible rude no manners obnoxious
what's it done
do you ever find moments where you think
[ __ ] i was just an [ __ ] then
i think that it's just time for people
you know you end up being
it's not that you can turn into that if
you're not one but
when you become busy it's a bit like you
know when people say that oh he's
changed
of course he's changed his life's
changed you know his responsibilities
change his business has changed
you can't expect him to say the same
people and you know when you have a
group of friends when you all come out
of school and sort of going from there
and
you're talking every day and the ones
that sort of grow
[Music]
the friendships are still as strong but
you just don't talk to each other
every week every day because you've got
your own life you've got your own vision
you've got your own plans
but you still go for lunch and you get
on better than ever and you met but
and it's the ones that say oh he's not
no he's don't talk to us anymore
i ain't got time mate but this just goes
back to the sacrifices
you know if i fall out with friends
because of what i'm trying to achieve in
my own personal life and my business
so be it i know again that that sounds
you know and it's not about being a bad
friend or a bad person but
you you can't you can't worry about
other people as long as you're a good
person as long as you do the right thing
the fact that you don't have time at the
moment
but that's when you people might
perceive you to be an [ __ ]
yeah you talked a little bit about that
about being 80 years old and looking
back on your life i'm gonna just play a
little
uh a little game with you so we've got
to imagine um
imagine that what day of the week was i
think it's tuesday today tuesday
so friday you find out that friday's
your last day
on earth my question is and really put
yourself there
right so friday's your last donut all
the fights coming up aj fury
all falls away what do you immediately
regret
that's actually something that i've
thought about quite a lot and the reason
was
is um about
four months ago my granddad passed away
it was 93 great life you know
and when i went to see him in his last
couple of days you know he obviously
didn't look great
and i looked at him i thought wow life's
crazy in it i said
everything that you've done in your life
and now you're laying here about to
leave
so when you get experiences like that
just you have to be reminded sometimes
that this is a game
life is a game we're only on borrowed
time right and you can never take
yourself too seriously i think that's
one thing i do well
is i love to have a laugh and i don't
take myself too seriously
um in answer to your question
since that moment i've been thinking a
lot about if i
you know if i went now do you look back
and say
i couldn't have done any more i had a
great time and i think the answer is yes
i mean we could all do we can all do
better
but my dad is an inspiration that
respect because he's the kind of person
that couldn't have squeezed one more
drop
out of his life right so i'm quite
envious of that he's 73
and who knows how long he's gonna last
but i do
feel like it's very important that when
you get to
whatever stage when god says that's
enough for
you that you are able to look back and
say i couldn't have done any more.
and that scares me a little bit because
i want to know exactly what
when you think about more you're saying
i could have done more
you find out that this friday is your
last day what are the things where you
think
do you know what because i think that
the
that moment like the the death bed
moment puts everything in perspective it
does but i think in that moment your
emotions are very different
to when you're well and fit and on the
hustle and just you know so
you don't get a chance to reflect on
that kind of moment until you're there
yeah and the obvious reflection at that
point is
i wish i would have spent more time on
my family you know
i wish i would have been less focused
probably on work
but i'm not a believer in you know the
thoughts then
are not the thoughts now and you have to
act on the moment you can't live your
life
saying well blimey when i'm on my
deathbed you might look back
in because i don't i don't think you can
plan like that you have to do what's in
your heart you have to do what feels
right
and what feels right for me right now is
this
sure what what might feel right then is
do you know what
should have probably missed a few trips
really and just done the school run a
little bit more and
and i know that you know you you have to
you really have to understand where you
are in life this is great for your
mental health as well and your sanity
you got to be honest with yourself and
and you gotta understand the situation
i know exactly where i'm at what i'm
thinking what i'm doing the sacrifices
i'm making
what i could do better at what you know
but i'm okay with it
you know you can't get the perfect
balance
but as long as you understand what is
going on and you're not deluded
you're not stubborn yeah
i know i know i need to do more at home
i know i need to do more school runs
i know i need to be less short with the
wife sometimes but can you
there's a couple of points here that i
think are super interesting so um
that death bed moment what i think it's
doing and i've never been there you've
not been there
but what i think it's doing is it's
telling you what actually mattered
because to some degree i think that it's
it's like
with that hindsight you can say [ __ ]
that person criticizing my hair or my
cut or this
none of that [ __ ] ever mattered all
of that was trivial but the things that
mattered was you say like
my niece or my you know so i think
that's what that moment so that comes
over time how do you now
2017. okay you're a baby yes right when
i was 27
what what people thought of me really
mad
you know i mean listen i've been working
out for 35 years just to stay fat
you know it's going a little bit i could
not give her
monkeys now at your age oh wait i was
you know
i might have been jack the lad i might
have been turning out that but deep down
you know i'd only take one of the boys
to say
you know tell you what edge you're
putting on a bit of timber there oh look
look you're barnett's creeping back
what what do you mean what do you mean
now okay yeah mate i know
listen signing the times isn't it so
being comfortable with yourself
is the best feeling in life you know
it's the best feeling in life and i
think when i was growing up at school i
wasn't
subconsciously i think i had a massive
chip on my shoulder and that's why i was
a bit of a bit of a
knob to be to be quite honest but when
you get
comfortable with yourself it's a
beautiful thing in life it really is you
know when you wake up in the morning and
you've always got to try for me and look
good and feel good and be the best
version of yourself you can be
but you do get to a stage and that's
actually when you become really powerful
and effective
you know it's the same kind of thing you
know when you're young and you're
courting or you're looking for
a young lady to show you some interest
you know when you try really hard
and you're sort of on edge and you be
don't really like my hair or
oh god you know you know the ones that
walk into the bar and just go oh my
you know i know i'm not the best but you
know
they're the ones that everybody
gravitates to anyone with a smile on
their face
is always creates so much more energy
and flow and the people that
don't and and that's about being
comfortable in yourself so
i think that it's very difficult with
everything you've achieved at your age
to just know where you're going or what
you're doing i'm done
do you know what i mean i'm i'm married
i've got two kids i've got business i'm
struggling to balance everything
you know but i'm here you know i'm not
gonna roll back
the the years and do this and do that
and i know exactly what i'm doing i know
exactly where i'm at
i know exactly what i'm focusing on and
that life
starts to become a lot easier then at
your age you know i went to work i left
college after my levels i went to work
for five years in sports management
companies and event management companies
i was a sports agent on a pga tour in
america i had no idea where i was going
i mean
i just wanted to be successful i wanted
to earn money
you know but the mindset of
or the changing mindset over the years
is unbelievable i always say to people
now what matters to you now you will
look back on when you get to my age and
go
i can't believe i even used to worry
about stuff like that
and that that's important because i i
feel like people that are very
successful
you know you did it at a very young age
very impressive because
i think it takes time now when i did the
cambridge uh talk the other day
you know you're sitting down with all
these young i mean i'm
i'm i'm street smart and i can sell
right these people are like
yeah i'm jealous of boffins i used to
take the mickey out of boffins
i'm jealous of boffins now i find
intellectual people fascinating i love
talking to them
and just trying to learn and absorb and
i'm sitting in this room with people and
they're listening to me and i'm thinking
you know firstly you must be listening
to me thinking
this boat who is he what is he a car
used car dealer something like that
and then but i'm i'm talking around i'm
saying to you what do you want to do uh
you know what what is success to you
they've not got a clue and it's not
because they're oxford and
they're deluded it's because that's just
it's very difficult that age to
understand
i don't believe anyone at faulty looks
back at
what they were thinking at 20 and said
yeah i had this plan i'm there now and
this is what i always wanted to do
so it takes time to develop a passion
for something and that that is the
that's a key word passion because when
we talk about being relentless and we
talk about this work ethic
you can only have it if you love what
you do and if you have a passion for
what you do i don't think you can trick
yourself
you can but you can't be as good you
know
you know you said um earlier that you
you feel like
you're self-aware of like the the lack
of balance in your life because you've
got this
real relentless streak you've got this
family and you're self-aware of it
do you think as much as you're aware of
it
do you think deep inside you you really
have a choice
or do you think you're being somewhat
dragged by your own ambition because
this is what i find fascinating about
people
successful people is it tends to be the
case that like me i'm aware i need to
see my niece more
but i just sometimes don't feel like i
have i'm fully in control
well i i do it because it's what i want
to do
ultimately i mean i do have an
obligation
you know i do have responsibilities i'm
talking about in the workplace sure
you know we've got a fantastic team here
but ultimately
when we're announcing a show when we're
doing a press conference when we do they
want me
sure they want their flesh so they roll
me out and i'm just like i'm like a
traveling salesman right eddie
announcing the show today off you go
right here we go bubba back in the car
here we go you know what
so but i do it because i enjoy it
because i love it
because i have an obligation to do it
for the business
that my father created
and of my responsibility now
is to take that to the next level you
know he built this from the foundations
from nothing
i'm not going to let it just fizzle out
as he goes into his 80s i want to take
it to the next level
but the difference is is i don't have to
do this
you know i'm not looking at this it's my
way out
um you know i'll just if i just make
some money i can
you know i can buy the lamborghini or i
could have done that at 21. but imagine
the eddie that that doesn't do this
imagine what
how do you feel but the same thing it
was that was me at school
now that was the kid telling the
teachers i don't have to do that you
know
that runs shivers down me give me some
advice on um
because you've got you're married and
i'm i genuinely
even genuinely no it sounds crazy but
i'm like
you've managed to crack it seems like
because you're married um
crack the balance of being relentless on
one end
but then managing to find a person or to
at least
keep them happy to some degree but yeah
i spoke to her but i genuinely
i started to think of the the last
couple years i'm like how am i going to
find someone that understands that i
want to send text messages at 4 am in
the morning
and that i sometimes don't want to talk
to them and that when i'm satisfied i'll
be quiet for seven hours because i've
just got an email that i'm thinking
about
and so i'm like is it that you have to
find the right person is it something
you say to them
i think they need to know you they need
to know
what drives you i mean if you had a
conversation with my wife
and you said what what is he like
you know she just go well he's just in
his own world isn't he i mean the amount
of times
you know that moment where you get home
and they go right i need to talk to you
and you go into
the kitchen and they go right now
isabella you know i spoke to her teacher
today
and um i'm gone right so i'm good i'm
going
and i'm thinking that contract's gonna
be in at 9pm you know
and she goes to me what did i say and
i'll go
this is cool what is it and she's just
she but it's not like
and she'll go listen we have blazing
rounds you know you're
you know you're so selfish all you care
about is work you know
but you again it just gets to a point
where you just have to understand
life you just nothing's perfect you know
you've got two people that love each
other
i've known her since you know my 20s
i've
i've changed we've both changed a lot
over the years but we've changed
together and we've grown together
and this is what i do you know and i
would have had that conversation with
her at some point
many years ago to the point saying look
nothing's going to get in my way i i
don't mean to sound horrible and
i love you and you know i want to spend
the rest of my life with you but you
have to understand me
you have to understand that this is
extremely important to me
not don't say this is the most important
thing to me because that'll get you bang
in trouble but
this is extremely important to me and i
think because she's
been around my family because she knows
how important it is
to us she kind of just gets it you know
and there'll be times where
she'll say did i hear you on the phone
last night at five o'clock in the
morning
i say yeah you know who's doing the
canelo deal or you know aj do or
she'll just look at me and go but over
time
you know i think they might the most
difficult thing is the early stages
of dating because it's very difficult
for a woman that they want
your attention you know people people
sometimes think that women want
uh you know money and you know the nice
house and of course
everybody does but they don't really
they want your attention
and they want your company and they want
your time and there are three things
that are very difficult to do
when you live that kind of lifestyle so
you do have to you know we'll do
i'll race back from somewhere and i'll
say right
you know tonight let's go for dinner and
i'll be naked i don't you know
hopefully she don't listen to this i
really don't want to go for dinner
tonight
but you have to do it and that's what my
dad has kind of always taught me
something you've got to do you've got
big we're big family people
my mum is from from the east end
she's old school as far as they're
concerned
the man goes out and puts the bread on
the table
and the wife looks after the man
old old old world that don't exist
anymore
but every morning or every night my mum
will iron my dad a shirt
and she will put it on his on the door
for him in the morning
if you want if your wife right say i say
we put her in this room we sat her down
with god and he said listen
you can decide what happens next with
eddie and his career
right so you can we can bring it to an
end and he'll spend more time with you
what do you reckon she would do she
could make the decision on
you your relentlessness and your career
how do you honestly think she would make
that
i think she because she knows how
important is to me i think she would say
no he he he he needs to do it he has to
do it
but i think the i think the hope is that
there is an end place or an end goal for
me
yeah but for me i don't
whether in 20 years time we we play this
back i don't
think i want to be 70
you know maybe even 60 70 80
doing this dealing with problems and
listen maybe i won't even make it that
long
but for me i definitely have the mindset
of not i want to get in and get out
but i do want to get that moment
where i do sit on the beach with a cigar
don't even smoke you guys but you know
and a whiskey don't even like whiskey
but you know i couldn't imagine the
picture at least
and go do you know what we've done it
we've done well but walking away
is the thing that at the moment would
kill me you know to be able
imagine when you wrap up shop and you
know this might be i mean for us we've
gone from being a family business
you know to having four employees to now
all of a sudden having hundreds
employees
in in multiple offices around the world
we're being approached
by for for investment for takeover for
ipos
and now we're sort of at that stage of
growth where i don't know
i just see i see a i see a faster exit
strategy
than my dad at least that's what i'm
selling to her
you know just give me a few more years
just give me a few more but i do want to
go and enjoy because
i can't say i'm not enjoying myself
because i love what i do but i do want
that moment to just
you know but it's the walking away you
know how do you just
one day turn around and you might sell
the business or you know you might float
and you take a
more of a backseat role that's difficult
because we make our own decisions we're
a hands-on business that's what we love
we've we've turned down investment and
opportunities for years because we don't
wanna
i don't wanna ball the directors we we
make the decisions
and we do what we wanna do because we
love what we do
but when you see such growth and you see
such interest and you see
the opportunity for you know
a much vaster wealth being quite honest
do you want it
and if you want it what's the exit
strategy
because at the moment the exit strategy
for our family is
from the day you start working from the
day you die you work your nuts off
every single day i mean it's not
particularly advanced is it
that strategy but that's just what we've
always done
mental health big topic you know
especially over the last
10 years i think if you go back well 10
years ago and you said the word mental
health people think people are crazy
right they think like um
run away from that person but now it's
become like the opposite it's like oh
someone's got you know
it's become something of where you'd
give someone affection and you take care
of them
because the stigma's somewhat changed we
know the stats around male mental health
have you ever suffered from any sort of
mental health
um predicaments
this is my favorite day of the week
my all-time favorite flavor of huel
berry i went up to hill's office in
tring last week and had another tour
around their headquarters and so
pretty amazing they have this massive
massive gym as you would you would you
would expect
but the thing that i didn't realize
about huel
was that it's also a vegan product and
also i didn't realize their commitments
to sustainability now there's tons of
reasons why you might choose to become a
hooligan like me
i've been drinking here for about three
years long before they um decided to
help me with the podcast and to sponsor
us
but i never realized that element of it
the reason i've always consumed tool is
because of convenience right
um some people might consume it because
it's nutritionally complete
um which i guess is part of the reason i
did as well and then some people might
consume it because it's affordable
but for me i never because i'm not vegan
i never realized it was vegan i never
realized their efforts around
sustainability
and i never realized it was also
gluten-free because again that's not a
problem i have
and so on this week's episode of the
podcast that's the key message that i
wanted to get across
is that if you are vegan and a lot of
people don't know this a lot of my
friends didn't know this
hewl is vegan too um
and this is my all-time favorite flavor
which is berry
um for me it tastes great um
20 grams of protein i'm currently trying
to get in better shape as you i hope
some of you have been able to notice if
you've seen
the podcast on youtube if you're
listening on youtube right now um yeah
and i love it and this is why it's so
awesome to work with a brand that you
believe in
because their impact on the environment
is low
they are good for you nutritionally it's
super convenient
and if you have the berry one it tastes
unbelievable so what a what a
win-win-win-win-win for me it was
working with you
because um i get to tell you guys about
something that i would swear by
and i don't have to be dishonest with
you um if you look at my fridge right
now
maybe you should take a look at it it's
pretty much all heal i'm not
advocating to have a heal-only diet but
that kind of speaks to the nature of my
life and how busy i am and and how many
meals i was missing before
i became a heel again have you ever
suffered from any sort of
mental health um predicaments
i don't think so no i mean i think
again depression's one of those things a
bit like yoga and breathing and stuff we
were talking about earlier
if you would have said to me 10 years
ago
listen maybe even five or six years ago
so and so suffering from depression
if if your perception of that person is
well he's young he's good looking
he's healthy he's rich he's successful
how can he be struggling from depression
what a load of rubbish
and actually it takes the older
generation even longer i mean i think my
dad's only just accepted now that it
exists
with people because his mentality is
what dust yourself down what's the
matter with you
and it's that's you know that that's
wrong because it is real
you know and it does exist um i don't
you know
have i had days where i've been feeling
incredibly down yeah but
surely that's normal you know i don't i
don't see myself suffering from that and
i think
i think mental health problems and
depression i think it comes from
overthinking
you know my um my brother-in-law is
hilarious he just i've never known
anyone
who just overthinks and worries
about stuff you know you're gonna be
having a conversation you'll go i've
just been thinking about that you know
and
and if that happens i was thinking you
know next year you could be there and
now
and then from there it's like whoa whoa
whoa what are you doing
just when you're struggling mentally
focus
on the short term focus on day by day
i think sometimes people look at and
this is the same for business when you
have
a project or a long-term plan there are
so many
short-term obstacles and goals to
overcome to get there
that's why many times you spoke someone
got this idea you know i'm going to be
doing this and that and that
and then a month later you've not even
heard about it oh well what happened was
we launched and then you know the
council came in or the regulation board
came in and
and this other company tried to do this
and and it just it's like no because
you didn't focus on the short-term goals
all you were worried about
was the house and the lamborghini and
you weren't prepared to to tick the
boxes to get there
so sometimes when i'm a little bit off
or
you know it might be traveling a lot and
the equilibrium has gone and it's like
okay
so i'm just gonna write down what i'm
gonna do today and it can be really
menial stuff it could be
walk the dog you know it could be
finalize a contract could be go to the
gym
it could be go and get some food you
know from
work just to say and and i would tick
everyone off really yeah and i would say
at the end of the day i would look at it
and i'll go
done and that's the momentum back that
that's where you get
the feeling of accomplishment even even
on tiny things
say okay i'm moving in the right
direction for me that
that is a big help for me he's
short-term focus
because once you start worrying about
what's going to happen next week or next
month or next year
no and you're going to start driving
yourself crazy you've just got to say
okay
this is what i need to do today and
tomorrow i need to do the same thing and
then before you know it
you'll start making positive changes
you'll start achieving because you know
what what you've set the targets you've
set yourself you are achieving you're a
bit of a philosopher i don't know if you
realize because um
there's a great famous philosopher that
says uh depression is too much
of the past and anxiety is too much
thinking too much about the future and
he says the cure is more now
and that's pretty much what you've done
yeah that's true because you can't worry
about things that may or may not happen
and you can't change things that have
already happened what you can do is
change what is happening today
and it's simple to do that again in in
the book i ran a marathon one marathon
right because my dad ran loads and he
took the mick out i mean i had to do it
and it's the same kind of thing you
start the marathon you think 26
miles if you start thinking about
running 26 miles
i mean i it did give me anxiety attacks
to start with i was thinking
that's just ridiculous i've never done
more than 10k and then you train you
train you train and you build and then
every mile marker is an obstacle
you start off you think 26 miles by me
and you go one two three four five and
you're you're okay and then
and then you're 12 13 you think i've
done half and you get to 18 19 you think
i can't do it anymore and you think
just get to 20 get to 2021 and when you
see that 20 mile marker
you know and then you get to 20 and you
go do you know what i've still got six
miles i can't do it and you go 21
22 23 and then when it's all over you
can look back but if you start worrying
about the future you're going to get out
you're not going to make it
do you feel that anxiety sometimes in
those big moments where you've got
you know some things coming up and you
just can't stop thinking about it um
in my business it was actually the first
you know i heard this term mental health
and
i think at the start i thought nah it's
not real and then a couple of years in
i see a lot of people i just started
hearing you know friends of mine and
stuff going through really bad things
i'm like
i think it's real and then i got to this
point where i was always scared to admit
that it would be real
because i almost felt like if i admitted
it was real then i'm like welcoming the
possibility into myself of like labeling
myself something
and then there was one moment where i
had this really big decision to make in
new york
and i'm laying in the hot tub in
manchester and
i just got really anxious and i was
anxious for about four days up until the
point of the decision
and then i thought that's probably the
closest i've come to some kind of mental
health predicament is that real
anxious feeling that i couldn't shake i
think social media is horrendous as well
like
i've made the decision in the last
couple of years
years specifically to start ignoring and
blocking out a lot of
um you're a celebrity now yeah
but when i was coming through when i was
overturning the system
the support was unreal and i was really
feeding off that i mean
anyone that says you know they're not
affected by criticism or they're not
worried about i mean that's a load of
rubbish
of course you don't like people
criticizing you and by the way you love
people
patting you on the back and championing
you of course it's natural what things
get to you though
stuff that people like the personal
stuff couldn't give
couldn't give monkeys about it's more
about
the it's it's more about people
when you're putting the work in
something and you're so passionate about
something
and you're actually working for the good
of might be the sport or whatever
it's the people that just you know
presume see you completely differently
so
that's the frustration but over the last
couple of years
i just started thinking to myself what
are you i was having a conversation with
man my old man's on twitter right and he
phoned me at me ago
i'm having an argument with this giza on
twitter right and he was going on about
the snooker in the format
and i said to him i'm like whoa whoa
whoa whoa i said are you serious
i said who is one who is this boat i
said you imagine someone stopping you on
the street and
having a pop at you about the snooker
format but it also it's it's the
platform
that made us what we are it got us to
the top you know the interaction with
the fans and the understanding of their
mindset
so we can't just you know but it's
become a toxic place
it really has you know and i worry for i
worry for my kids
you know sometimes one of them be on
tick tock and
she'll put a dance out and someone will
come back and say say
you know i don't know uh you're ugly you
look really you're stupid you know and
it's like we never had that now they
i mean we never even had a phone you
know if someone didn't like you they
might say something in the playground
but that's about it so
we live in a world of criticism and i
think it's a negativity
but that's what i said to my old man
said you imagine like these people
they're all doing it all day i'll put a
post out and it's the same ones all the
time
i don't think you know i mean even um to
the point where someone posted my phone
number
on twitter right and i've had my phone
number
for 25 years
same one right and someone posted it and
went
give it this is eddie hearn's number
give him a call and you know tell him
what you think about the pay-per-view
price or whatever it is
and my phone was going men's like it was
like every
literally all day it was just private
number private number and i thought you
know what
you got to change your number and i
thought i can't be bothered so i started
answering a few
right and to this day this was a few
years ago
it's that people still do it and there's
this one guy
you've got the same number yeah i can't
be bothered to change it right
so this guy's private number private
number private number
and it's all day right so i pick it up
and i go
hello mate and he goes oh
bloody hell eddie and i go yeah how you
doing mate
and he goes uh um
when you're gonna stop ripping us off on
the paper views or something like that
right and i go
and it and i went to him mate let's have
a serious conversation
what are you doing and he goes what do
you mean
what am i i said have you got a job and
he's like
uh yeah i mean i said you haven't have
you and he's like well
not not at the moment i said what are
you doing
i said how many times have you phoned me
today
oh i mean the answer was like 40
right i said you can't focus i said all
the energy
you're putting into phoning me because
you think it's banter or
is some kind of accomplishment if i pick
up the phone i said put it into
something worthwhile
i said because you really waste in your
life
and he just went quiet and he's like uh
oh come on no eddie what about a few
quid off the paper view and i'm like no
no mate
i'm serious but i want to help you
you've got to
you've got to change you know and then
you just hung up
and i thought [ __ ] okay but it's true
isn't it what are you doing
what are you doing i mean all right once
might be quite funny you know i'll pick
it up and you give me a bit
but all day every day you know
because i'd hate to be one of those
people that just wakes up every morning
with no fire in the belly with no
passion with nothing
and there are by the way that's 95 of
the population
many people it's why it's so important
to me here
to create an environment a mattreum for
the for the team
where you enjoy being there you know
we've got we get food together we've got
a gym we've got a pool we've got
we're all traveling away to events we'll
have a night out do that because
you can't be in a job or a life where
you just flat
how am i going to get the best out of
you if you don't love what you do and
it's very difficult to have that same
passion when it's not your business
you know so motivation is important but
you know frank said to me he said
he said uh you know eddie's a and he's a
businessman that's that's
where you came from your dad's a
businessman too and with this new age of
social media and all the interviews you
do on youtube and you are relentless
with the interviews as well by the way
and i was when i saw you in new york uh
on that rooftop with like the nice
garden stuff yeah
you were back to back to back doing
those interviews with all these bloggers
for three hours
that's helped grow the business it's why
most people know matroom
especially of this generation but it's
made you a celebrity and frank said to
me he said
i don't think he's enjoying the
celebrity thing you know and i think a
lot of people would be really really
surprised to hear that
because you know
people would they think that you'd love
it they think you love the attention i
mean promoters are in the business of
attention right
but from a personal perspective
apparently you don't like it you don't
like the celebrity
i then set out to be a celebrity and i
set out to be a businessman
i set out to um
continue the success that my dad built
but i do recognize that if i am
well known if i am a showman if i am a
celebrity
it will help me push my events it will
help me push the profile
of fighters you know you get to a stage
now where the industry haters might say
oh well
it's ridiculous he's doing all these
interviews you know he's more popular
than most of his fighters
you know more popular as a wrong word
well known than zombies
but that's me you know i look at the
success of the ufc i look at the growth
of
of that business and dana white and
every major
fight sport um product has that lead guy
in wwe it's vince mcmahon you know in
mma it's dana white and in boxing i
guess
it's me or you know i want it to be me
so there's a method to the madness
and but you know the book
the book was something that i wanted to
do because i just thought it was funny
that i would ever write a book right how
do you think it's funny no but if you
knew me at school and you knew i just it
was more like
hodder put it to me during before
lockdown and when lockdown come
i panicked and i was like
oh and next you know talk about being at
home with you kids now i'm at home with
my kids and i've got no events
and oh so i was just like for those
first two weeks i was just
right we launched a fitness show with
sky that people could do at home fight
and fit
you know i've said to the guys here give
me that book deal i'll write it now
let's do the book now and i wrote it in
lockdown you know
and it was just zooms more zooms more
interviews because
i just i was just scared of not having
that
drive every single day of you know going
out there and and
and i didn't enjoy it like an illness
he's an illness let's be honest we're
all sick aren't we i mean like
you can't do you can't wake up in the
night every night
and start writing emails doing contracts
texting people right and then wake up at
seven
and do the school run and then drive to
work and do it all over again every
single day
unless you're a little bit ill in the
head you can't actually be
still like so when you talk tell her
about that cigar moment in the future
sitting on that beach
i didn't believe you for a second yeah
you're probably right but i just i'd
like to think that it's
at least what i'm telling to miss is
that one day we'll be we'll chill out
you know what i mean
could you imagine laying on a beach with
a cigar like this no emails no nothing
just
no fights coming up nothing just
meditating
no but i think it all depends where you
get to
you know it's like when you're building
your stack at poker you know
the problem with gambling is you never
know when to walk away
right and we're not gambling anymore
because we're very good at what we do
but
life is always a gamble so when you
build your stack
it's that moment when you say to the
cashier can i get a rack please
and you put it in your rack yeah and you
go up to the cashier's desk and you say
cash out in for me and i go
sue and you walk away and you go yeah
and then you get sit down you're gonna
have a nice beer but that moment sucks
you said the moment the that moment
doesn't suck but then after
again it's the thrill isn't it yeah i
like to win i like people
so the thing that would hurt me more is
if i turn around tomorrow and win
i couldn't have done any more in boxing
i'm out
bye what would hurt me more is sitting
on the beach
not not you know enjoying myself going
now i'm gone all those people that i was
fighting again for all those years to
become number one they've got no
they're back you know they're back and
that's what my dad walked away from
boxing
because it is the most um aggravating
business an intense business and that's
what i'm saying about
it all throughout the night because
everyone's trying to [ __ ] you
non-stop right so you have to sleep with
one eye open
and i think he got to a stage where he
went i don't want to do this anymore i'm
going to go and do darts
where everyone's going to love me do
what i mean and i'm jealous of look at
that because i saw growing up
this guy that was so intense and who had
a bad temper and
you know and then all of a sudden once
boxing went
he was just chilled out wow i can't
believe what's happened to my life so
you know i i hate to let people win and
if i left
ultimately they would win but i guess
the only time you can walk away is when
you're
content and will the contentment ever
come
at the moment like you say possibly not
but who knows you know who knows where
we can build to where we can get to
where it might be that moment and again
you have to always leave the option open
because as i said
your thoughts at 20 are totally
different to your thoughts at 30
and 40 and 50. i may get to 50 and we
may be
you know i've had another great 10 years
and i might go
fire's not there anymore i'm done or i
might be saying right now i want to take
over music now i want to take over
football
now you know so it's difficult to say
and with the
family businesses they're a very special
thing and in the world in the world we
live in today
these big global corporations and the
public markets growing it's very rare
for a family business to withstand the
temptation
of acquisitions or going public or
whatever what
who can you don't have a son right and
uh i'm wondering who continues the
family business if you were to go down
that route is it
no well that's a good point because that
is the the conversation
you know ever since i started to
understand
business more for me that that is a
natural progression of a family business
to go
family business you know investment or
acquisition or ipo and that's what you
do
because how do you i have i have
aspirations for this business to grow
globally
and to study staging events in every
major territory in the world
you know to do that does require
huge investment does it does require you
know management
it and we can do it but that's not our
speciality our speciality is creating
great live events for our broadcasters
and fans
okay so my dad has always said to me
i will never ever ever
take investment for the business float
the business
or sell the business and i've always
over the years gone yeah but
you know it's gotta we gotta get to it
and actually
the the something's quite interesting
you know i've been blessed with two
amazing daughters of course
every man with quite a lot of son didn't
work out that's what god gave me
but there is it's an interesting point
because
my end goal if i had a son and listen
only 41 who knows
but i think it would be more
you know here we go again down the line
kind of thing with me i would quite like
to
end the journey
with my dad joe to me to say
look at what we you know not it's gone
but look at where we started look at
where we finished
because it's very difficult and i take
the interest
from you know hedge funds and you know
investment funds
with unbelievable amount of compliment
to say well you know and
the calls are coming in non-stop because
they appreciate
the model of growth where when we talk
about one sport one promoter one belt
you know that mindset
it's a carbon copy of the ufc now the
ufc sold 4.6 billion
there is no reason why boxing
with with so much more history with so
much more credibility with fans and
broadcasters
can't replicate that model and actually
be even more valuable than the ufc
business
and i'm really the only chance it has
to do it it's not going to be bob harrem
it's not going to be don
king it's not going to be frank warren
it's going gonna be me so
all of a sudden i've been giving
interviews like that and then the calls
are coming well
right we want you know and it's like
guys we're not we don't need it we're
not if i wanted to go and get funding
if i wanted to go and float i'll do it
tomorrow but it's a big
it's a big you know head-butting system
with me and
me and my dad and you know he's starting
to
look and i'm just saying we can't just
be blind to it
it's a natural progression for any
business in terms of growth
to look at these models and but is that
why you're doing the business
because you know the happiness you've
got from this business i
i would guess and i run i ran a public
business until recently
um much of it aggravation loads you
don't necessarily want right quarterly
reported
you gotta hit the numbers if you don't
then you've got to do something short
term that's not necessarily in the long
term interest of the business
right so i i i'm almost quite jealous
of the setup you have the control you
have you have it in your family and
you're happy but but you're someone that
almost needs forward
momentum to continue to be to be just
growth isn't it you know you know that
as a family business you know we we
you know you can see in our financial
results we're fantastic you know we're a
huge
uh family business in terms of the
numbers that we're delivering year on
year end
yes but at the same time
you're almost capped by the growth and
by the numbers
within the currents within that setup
yeah you know
okay so when you start you turn a
break-even business into a
a 5 million ebitda company and then
before you know it the aim is 10 and
15 and now we're 30 and you know but
how'd you get to 4 billion
why does 4 billion matter that's just
the ufc number you know so but
because why it matters is
it was never on the agenda it was never
possible it could never be done
and i guess it goes back to the
competition with my dad where i'm saying
you know i believe
you know when you talk about pe ratios
and the value of a business yeah we know
what we're worth now
but i do believe we have the potential
to be worth those kind of numbers
and that would be your success in some
respects
it's a game it's a game steve it's not i
don't know it's not like
i don't i don't think that deeply to i
just see it as a game but when you start
thinking deeply it doesn't make you
question so yeah it's good point why
does
i don't know i i just i live in the
moment i live in now i just feel that
every day we're trying to expand we're
trying to push the boundaries of trying
to do more so
would i like to this business to you
know
sell or have a value of for [ __ ]
right why
because it could it's ridiculous we're
just a couple of
like he's out of dagnam i'm his son
would be a great story yeah but it
it's just it's us against the world
because the money would do to be honest
nothing
the money wouldn't change my lifestyle
at all i'm not i've got a couple of nice
cars right i got a nice house
i don't want a yacht i don't want to jet
i don't want i mean well i mean
we'll talk about it but you know i don't
i don't want for anything i'm not
i'm at the age now maybe when i was in
my twenties
yeah wow yeah private jet he got you
just rent it
if you need it so it's just it's just
the fact that
what we've done i think i think legacy
is um i was talking to freddie flintoff
on my podcast and i said i said about
legacy
and he went yeah i think legacy's a load
of bollocks i actually i disagree a
little bit because
you know when you go back to that moment
where you're on your deathbed and you
might be today or
and when you've achieved something like
that you just you put yeah you start
laughing
you got i can't believe we've done it i
can't believe we've done it and that
would be
the better kind of memories or the
achievement to me you know
can you believe we've done it but you've
got to enjoy it at the same time but
you know i don't know it's you could you
can debate this all
day long because you sit back on the
death bed and you say yeah but was i
really happy
of course because this is bringing us
happiness this is i know that every day
i come in here
and i'm smiling and i'm up for it and
i'm passionate and i'm full of energy
and i've got a drive and a fire in my
bed that's good enough for me my dad
comes in
every day has been coming here you know
into this off into this business for
50 45 years and he's got the same
passion
the same energy that he did when he
first started the company
that's got to tell you something and
this is almost
somewhat of a contradiction because he's
coming in here every day
you're both really really happy you're
coming in here with a fire on your belly
but then there's this other part of you
that's like but we need the
end point yeah he doesn't he doesn't he
he
he doesn't want any of that you know
he's going ah son we've got the most
amazing business
you know we're forecasted to just for
continued growth
for the next five ten years we've got
broadcast contracts locked in
we're untouchable and i'm like yeah but
how do we go you know i want offices you
know we have offices in
in england in new york in milan
in madrid i want offices in sydney in
toronto in mumbai
in beijing that that's what i want why
because we're not supposed to have it
we were never supposed to be this
business i was never supposed to be this
kid so it sounds like you're proving
something to
somebody maybe but probably to him
and if that's what it comes down to
which comes back to your childhood
probably
and if you prove that to him right you
have all these offices around the world
you sell for five billion
will that make you happy probably not
but i don't know i i i don't think that
rebellion for 5 billion and making a
load of money will make me happy
it will make me happy to be able to say
i can't believe we've done it you know i
can't believe
what we've achieved but then you'll need
the next thing part possibly
or that might be the the cigar on the
beach moment i wrote i wrote this one
sentence in my book where i
started to understand the moment i
described at the start when someone made
me an offer for my business
and i looked at it when i was 23 and i
thought we've got 25 million quid
[ __ ] and then what i learned in that
moment is
my whole life became so confused and i
almost fell into like i'd call it chaos
and so in my book i write that we live
our lives thinking that we're striving
for stability which would be
completed goals the cigar um
thinking that stability of stability and
that we're trying to escape chaos but
what i came to learn was
in fact um our stability is chaos
it's the having unanswered goals and
it's the problems and it's the forward
motion
so our chaos is stability and our
stability
the cigar moment would actually feel
like chaos
yeah it would feel like some kind of
text if it wasn't time
if it wasn't time and we don't know when
it'll be time yeah but what you just
said there is very true because
like any athlete that moment
when they're in the chaos is where they
feel most at peace with themselves
you speak to any fighter and you say
where would you rather be
anywhere in the world and say in the
ring and that's the same for us
so it's not like i want aggravation but
stick me in it
put me in front of problems and and tell
me i can't do something
that's where i'm in my moment am i in my
moment where i'm sitting at home
you know watching tv no i'm i'm at my
best
when i'm doing those 100 200 interviews
or i've got problems or a fight's
falling
through and you know all of a sudden the
shit's hit the fan that's when i'm at my
best
so and that's where i do feel calm in a
way you know at first
when you have problems you know it might
be a panic but for me okay
this is what we do we go to work now you
know and that's that's the same for an
athlete or a fighter
that's when they feel calm when you
might be watching going
because that's not your your calm that's
not your your moment
it's their moment i'm fine you know when
aj fights he ain't nervous
i'm [ __ ] [ __ ] myself because i
can't control it it's not me it's not
what i do but that's what he does
you know when when a fight's falling
through or it looks like a massive
show's about to be cancelled
and other people in here might be oh oh
do you think you'll be all right do you
think we'll do
well and i'll just lock the door and say
right leave me alone and i go to work
that's my that's that's no problem for
me
you know but but you only become
exceptional at things and used to things
when you become familiar with them
and when you put yourself in the same
position time and time again
it's all about frank you know we we
always laugh about him giving his press
conferences
you know because when i did my first
ever press conference which was audrey
harrison against david haye
i couldn't stop shaking you wouldn't
have known it the time but i put my
hands on the table like this
and i and i could i could feel them you
know i could i could see them going so i
just when i spoke i just put them
underneath
my legs like this and just leant forward
and you would never have known
and when i done the next one a little
bit less and the next one and then
within five or six
i never needed notes i just speak you
know
four hours i couldn't believe it and
with frank you know he done one recently
and i could see him shaking you know i
was just taking the piss out of him and
i just said just keep doing it keep
doing it repetition repetition
keep putting yourself in situations
steve davis who is my godfather
i said to him once how do you you know
when you
you talk about sort of sports where
millimeters make a difference it's
nothing more than snooker you know
i said how do you do not get nervous you
know you're about to go down to pot the
blackboard and just little one little
jolt and it's all over and he said i
have no nerve endings
he said because i've been put in the
position time and time
again in the end it's just it's second
nature
it's just like riding a bike and that's
that's what the same with business
you have to keep putting yourself in a
position time and time again and you'll
keep improving
listen thank you for your time today
no it's another counselling session yeah
you know i'm going to leave it now and
go away
you know i think the best the best thing
you can talk about
mindset and and mentality and
for hours and hours and hours just keep
it simple
don't over complicate things don't
overthink things
be happy keep smiling that's difficult
when you want something so bad and
you're chasing it but if you start to
really overanalyze
that's when you know things start
creeping in just keep it simple
and um you know i said sometimes if
things get tough or
you know we've got problems and i'll say
tomorrow man he said don't worry he said
just wake up an hour earlier tomorrow
and go to bed an hour later
i'm thinking that's so that's so and he
is the most simple mindset
but it works for him because you and the
best thing you can do is be honest with
yourself
as well just try and understand take a
step back and just
think about what is happening in the
world and your world right now
and if you can understand it you can
deal with it and you can solve it
but just think simple thank you
you